congratulations you survived bet
presents the encore and you all
absolutely crushed the big performance
at the end
[Music]
now i know that pamela has since left
the group but what are the plans for
blueprint moving forward tour album what
can we expect so we're going to release
this ep and hope that the fans are
really excited about it and that they
love it and that they they really
appreciate the blood sweat and tears
lots of tears that went into making this
ep for them
100 i mean look it was such a joy as a
viewer to really feel like i was part of
the experience with all of you ladies as
you were there making your music
is there gonna be a season two a part
two are you ready to put your lives back
on tv again
we have no idea
yeah well how are you feeling are you
down for it do you want to do it
i don't know let's see what that check
talking about
shamari how are you feeling about the
whole experience i think i think the
experience was was great i love the
music like you said um it's the the
performance that's my favorite part
about just being an entertainer so of
course i would love to go on tour with
blueprint i would love that so i mean
hopefully like we are releasing the ep
but i want to go further than the ep
like i want to travel like i want to do
big things with blueprint because i feel
like we have a chemistry and a lot of
people are probably shocked not you know
once they see and they the performance
how much of a chemistry that we actually
have together um and how much we connect
so i feel great about everything and i'm
just super excited and um i just hope
the fans just love everything that we
put out and everything that we do
[Music]
keely i want to ask you because we saw
you throughout the journey flip-flop a
little bit you were cool being on stage
you wanted to be more of a creative
director then you absolutely crushed it
on stage where are you feeling with all
of this right now
the same way i was before i mean i could
take it or leave it guys but i was hard
for like producers to edit because it's
like she doesn't really care that much
so it's like it was hard for them to
like give give something i wouldn't want
to be in any other girl group
except for this one i can genuinely say
that i did not want to be in this one
but now now that i'm in it um and and
i've gotten to work with these ladies in
a different way um and we've started to
kind of
build that trust that i look for in girl
groups i am very honored
all right well shimari just mentioned a
tour so i'm hoping that if there is a
tour you're going to be there with the
rest of these queens you better not miss
it i love it so if we look back at the
whole journey of course we said goodbye
to some of your your your bandmates
along the way um where do you guys stand
with the rest of the ladies with misha
and with irish and with aubry and with
nivea
got nothing for love but love for
nothing but love man and i think some of
us you know still i think shimari really
is keeps in touch with a a few of them
um but like felicia said nothing but
love we all had an experience and we
learned from it and we've grown from it
and i just think that every single one
of those women were there for a reason
and we did everything that we came to do
yeah 100
i mean
is blueprint solidified as a foursome or
is the door open if these ladies who
were at the beginning of the project
part of it if they wanted to maybe
revisit it is the doorbell wants to come
back she is more than welcome and the
door is open
girl what you need me to do you could
take all my vocals
background do it a little two-step
and support you
because nivea was such a huge loss um to
the show but also to the group i mean
and i think that that
as you saw like in the last few episodes
was really one of the more one of the
biggest driving forces for me to
actually join the group was just the
weight of nivea's departure was like
really heavy on all of us and i'm not
saying that i at all could fill nivea's
shoes but
that really was the driving force
because she was just
such an inspiration to everybody she was
such a light to everybody
and you know something big needed to
happen
if nivea is gonna leave if she would
like to come back i would love nivea
yes
i love you
alan and felicia how do you feel
the same i mean
if maybe you want to come back she can
come back any time yeah what about what
about the other ladies i think that i
think that's the only thing that you
want to come yeah so
[Laughter]
well you just threw a lot of love at
nivea i i do want to ask you about aubry
my group sold way more than yours put
some respect on my name she announced
that she was leaving the united states
in search of a new life is there any
message that shamari you would like to
send her
good luck and good writtens
that's an interesting response
keeley how do you feel
good luck
i mean i i second chamari's opinion but
also good luck um i think you can tell
when you watch the show i mean at least
i could tell when i watch it back who's
there for what reasons i think you can
really clearly see who was there
to really make something who was like
super passionate even if it made them
look bad sometimes i just feel like
audrey wasn't really there to really be
a part of the group in the first place
she was never there i feel like it was
just fake and she was there for show so
um yeah so good luck in whatever you
know your future endeavors are but it
was really fake to me she was very fake
because there is no formal reunion for
bet presents the encore i'd love if we
could just take this moment fallon and
felicia is there anything you want to
get off your chest that you would
normally say in a reunion
oh my god
um
man that i'm really not a [ __ ]
i'm very passionate person i think that
i am i'm a jokester most i will say that
we spoke a lot a lot more than a lot of
the all of the other girls on camera so
that's what they took and that's what
they showed and also and also we're
twins so it's gonna seem like a yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because it's two of
us with huge personalities and sometimes
you know it may
make somebody wanna you know slap you in
the face but we can dish it and we can
take it so yeah just know that
i'm down for a season two hopefully if
we do it so i just wanted to
leave the u with those words
[Music]
you
[Applause]